In this video, let's look
at RStudio's pro tool set
and how you can use RStudio
Workbench to create new
JupyterLab sessions.
You also have the choice
of using Jupyter Notebook
or VS Code with Python, but in
this case, let's start there.
Well, then publish
to RStudio Connect
so stakeholders can see and
view and easily understand
that data.
So let's open this new
JupyterLab session.
And the beautiful thing
about RStudio Workbench
is that you can
authenticate users,
you can have the resources that
are needed on this platform
and share the various resources
between your collaborators.
So I have this example that
I've already put together.
And so in this case,
we have all this data
from the Center for
Near-Earth Objects
or asteroids and
comets from NASA.
And so I've got a
lot of columns here,
way more than I want to
work with, about 40 or so.
But what I want to do
is just get to about 15
of those columns and
understand the data a bit better.
So I've put together this
JupyterLab Notebook,
and in this case, you
can see that we've
pulled in some Python
visualization libraries
that we're going to use, like
Pandas, Seaborn, Plotly Express.
And we can use those to take
a closer look at the data.
So here we have a column
list that we've just
pulled in that
specific data that we
would like from the
CSV file using Pandas,
we're reading that CSV.
And then we have our
column list above which
we're pulling in here.
So to make it a little
easier to understand
the data I have
renamed my columns,
you can, you know,
of course, just use
the columns that come existing.
But in this case, we're
displaying the first five rows
to get a quick view of that.
And I've also broken my data
down by asteroids and comets
based on the orbit class,
which helps you to do that.
So we've broken
that data up a bit
with Pandas. Now using Seaborn
you could start to do things
like visualize that data.
There are some things that we're
doing to observe the data here.
In this case, you know,
we're using Plotly
to have a more
interactive visualization.
We can see the majority
of these comets
or actually, yeah,
comets in particular
have been discovered in
the last two decades.
And then going down,
there's other ways
we could look at the data.
But the point here is that
we've done a few things
to plot our data.
And then we can,
you know, describe
that data some and maybe even
have some things that we embed
in this document,
like in this case,
we've got the ability
to embed, you know,
HTML and more visualize some
things from NASA and so on.
But you get the
basic point, you've
got a data glossary here.
So let's take this
Jupyter Notebook now,
and we'll publish it
directly to RStudio Connect.
So to do that,
you'll actually need
to open a new session
in RStudio Workbench.
And so we have the option
to have a JupyterLab
session or a Jupyter Notebook
session to build our notebook.
But to publish it we'll
actually go to Jupyter Notebook
to do this inside of
RStudio Workbench.
And once we have this
session open then we'll see,
we have another option for
publishing to RStudio Connect.
So we'll go to
that same notebook.
And once this is open and
we'll give it a moment,
we'll have the option
to publish directly.
So now we see we have
this option for publishing
to RStudio Connect.
And the first time
that we do this
we'll actually have a dialog that
pops up and will have the need
to bring in our server
name, server address.
So once we have that.
And we'll also want to go
back to RStudio Connect
and get an API key.
OK, so once we've logged
into RStudio Connect,
we see in the top right corner
that we've got the user login
icon, let's select
that and then you
can select API keys to
set up this initial key.
So we're just going to
set up a new key here,
and then once we have
that, we'll copy it.
We can select that to
copy or just select here,
and we'll close this out and
go back to RStudio Workbench.
We'll paste in that API key
from RStudio Connect, and just
give this a name as test server
and use the default secure
connection settings.
We'll add this server.
Then when we publish
this, we have the option
to either publish the document
with the source code
or publish the finished document
only as a static notebook.
In this case, we want to publish
the document with the source
code, and then we'll
also select the files
that are associated with it.
So we're going to actually
select the CSV file
and then there was an image
file for that notebook as well.
OK, so now we're going to
publish using the existing
requirements.txt file.
We could also generate one if
we needed to but in this case,
we already have one,
so we'll publish it.
And we'll set this
as a new location.
And publish.
So let's take a look at this
"SpaceTracker" notebook that's
inside of RStudio Connect.
So we have this loading here
with our table and our plots,
and everything is functional
from the HTML standpoint
within RStudio Connect.
The great thing about
this is that now we
can share this actual set
of data and information
with end users in a way
that we can control.
So we could have it
so that anyone could
login and view this document.
We may have specific users
that we want to set up.
So in this case, we'll
set up "Profound Publisher"
to have access.
And then we can set, you
know, copy this URL and share
that with them to use anywhere.
And another thing
that you can see here
is that we can schedule this
document, so in this case,
you could set a particular
time for that to run.
In this case, I have a CSV file,
but you could have live data
that you've connected
to here, and this
could rerun that document
at a particular time
and even send that off
to them in an email
and publish it to them.
So this is really helpful to
control that the information is
current. Now the end
user has full access
and can easily take a look
at this notebook anywhere
and be able to see the
particular data live
and totally up to date.